وعندما يقول زوج كيليان كونواي
إنه غير لائق للمنصب ، هل توافق على
هذا التقييم ، فأنا أفعل ذلك ،
لكنني اعتقدت أنه عندما كان
يترشح وليس بالضرورة السبب العقلي
قال إنهم تحدثوا عنه ولكن
لأنه لم يكن لديه الخبرة
التي تعرفها  الكثير من الأشياء المختلفة ،
فكيف ترى هذه النهاية الآن ، هل تنتهي
في صندوق الاقتراع في عام ، هل
يصل إلى فترة ولاية ثانية هل يستقيل
نتيجة العزل ما تعتقد
أنك تعلم أنه أمر مضحك يسألني الناس
هذا وأنا أفكر أنك تعلم أنه من الصعب أن
أقول رأيي على التلفزيون الوطني لأنني
قد أكون مخطئًا جدًا ولكن
دعني أخبرك بما اعتقدت أنني أعنيه
أعتقد أنه يفعل الكثير من الأشياء
لحفظ ماء الوجه وأنا  يمكن أن يعطيك أمثلة
ليس لدينا وقت ولكن أعني أنه كانت هناك
بعض الأشياء التي تعرف أنه لا يستطيع
السيطرة عليها وهو الآن في مرحلة
لا يستطيع فيها التحكم في هذا الأمر ، ولا يمكنه فعل
أي شيء حيال ذلك
سيء للغاية بالنسبة له ليتم عزله
أنا لا k  الآن بعد أن ثبتت إدانته
لكنني لا أعتقد أنه يريد
عزله ، أعتقد ، نعم ، أعتقد أن
هذا هو سبب هذا الذعر وأخبرني حدسي
أنه سيترك مكتب هيلاري
أو يعقد صفقة ما
اعتمادا على ما يخرج